today's talk is about certain aspects of
the execution model used by the mill
architecture the mill is a family of CPU
designs family in the sense of the 360 a
due to the advances in the architecture
the it's a commercial product or we hope
it will be it's still in development and
it offers a 10x power performance
advantage over existing architectures
this is an architectural advance it is
not a circuit advanced it is not a fab
advanced we use exactly the same run of
the fab circuits and standard rules as
anybody else it is an architectural
advantage it does so without requiring a
rewrite of your program it does so
without requiring multiple core or
multiprogramming that you can of course
multi-core multi program Mills just like
anything else and it's just as much a
pain in the butt on the middle as it is
on anybody else this particular talk I
have to back up a little bit and speak a
little bit do describe the way data is
move back and forth internally in the
machine the mill has no general
registers it uses a different device and
I have to explain that a bit this was
actually covered in considerably greater
depth roughly a year ago may or
thereabouts-- here and the complete talk
of that is both available on this read
the 380 website and on ours and a much
greater detail at other locations given
that as a background I'll talk a bit
about how phasing permits us to triple
the effective ILP instruction level
parallelism of existing codes how we are
able to combine the computational
capacity of the Machine so as to support
novel operations that a conventional
machine cannot do and how that gets used
in order to avoid the problems using
condition codes
to indicate a boolean values I lastly or
speak briefly on the subject of how n
way branching is performed and how but
when you have multiple calls in a single
instruction how these cascade this is a
series of talks that this is the six of
them all the prior talks videos are
available on our website at that address
those of you are taking the class for
credit your homework assignment is to
review the material at that location
there will be a test and a caution this
talk is a gross oversimplification the
guts inside a CPU are fiendishly
complicated and depend on hardware and
other details that cannot be covered in
to talk of this nature instead I try to
convey an intuitive understanding
suitable for a non-specialist your
assumed to have some idea what goes on
in CPU but we're not going to get in any
great detail I'm open to questions after
the talk and I can go into all the
detail you'll ever want but the talk
itself doesn't do that reality is much
more complicated than this chocolate
again we try not to oversimplify but
sometimes so a few words on the belt as
I said that the machine has got no
general registers but you do have to get
the result from one add into the
multiplied that you have to use the next
data with and that requires a
communication device the mill is the
first of a new category of processors
called a belt machine there are numerous
other categories their stack machines
and accumulator machines and general
register machines and so forth these are
categories is lots of different
architectures within a category there's
lots of possible belt machines the mill
is one it is a point in that design
space the communication device looks
like a conveyor belt
it is a fixed length 50 assume that that
is a set of values sitting on the belt a
functional unit can read any position in
that 50 pulling values off it down into
the functional unit new results always
drop on the front of the belt
unconditionally you do not specify a
destination for your computation however
it's a fixed length so when you drop a
new one on the front well that pushes
the oldest off the back and it is gone
permanently the functional units there
there are many the mill is a wide issue
machine in the sense that a single
instruction can contain many operations
like a VLIW does if fair warning a
terminological trap here most people are
used to thinking that an ad is an
instruction once you're in the white
issue world and add is not an
instruction and that is an operation and
there may be a ton of other operations
in the same instruction so in this case
you can have three different functional
units which will be independently
grabbing values off of the belt and in
due course when those functional units
are ready to retire and a result all of
their results drop onto the front of the
belt and push corresponding numbers of
operations off the back addressing into
the belt is addressed by relative
position so this for example might be an
assembler language operation this has
ADD b3 Bell position three do bell
position five note no destination that
it results are implicitly dropped on the
front the B 3 and B 5 are there if you
think about it you realize that b3 is
the fourth most recent value to have
dropped to the belt and b5 is the six
months recent value to have dropped to
the belt
so this is temporal addressing it is not
spatial addressing you're not saying put
something in our six and it stays in our
sex this says pick up the value
indicated by the temporal order in which
you have got originally placed upon the
belt so a consequence of this is that
every time you do a new drop on the
front everybody's temporal address
changes so that for example if we want
to reference that value eight in red
there that is b3 now but as soon as a
few more values drop onto the belt b3
now refers to somebody else and that
valuators now be six this is a truly
awful process to attempt to kite track
of by hand the mill is not designed to
be an assembly language target however
this is trivial for a compiler to keep
track of and it is no more difficult and
the problems involved in for example
that register coloring and similar
things for a compiler now so much feel
about talking about going to talk about
phasing operations connect through data
flow paths such that the result of one
operation is the input to a next and the
chain of such items is a data flow
frequently a data tree but for most of
what I can show on a slide you can only
fit so much on a slide we're going to be
looking at linear data flows rather than
treats a consequence of the way the mill
is organized is that we are in fact able
to execute faster than then the clock
rate would appear to make possible I
want to emphasize that this is a
programming model the underlying reality
does not have a time tunnel inside it
there is no black hole and spinning
black hole that permits you to do
multiple things at once um so I will be
explaining a little bit about
how the hardware provides a solution but
from the viewpoint of the running
program effectively we get a significant
speed up and you'll see how now a data
flow is a chain of operations which are
dependent things if there is no gap such
the ad goes directly to the model player
goes directly the subtract you know goes
directly to the store unit with no time
gaps at all the fastest speed determine
is determined by the latency of the
individual operations an ad takes one
cycle and multiply Texas recycles the
subtract X 1 cycles well you know that
the fastest you're going to get is this
going to take five cycles to go through
all about because its immediate one
after another this limit based on the
propagation delay of the data who has to
be passed through is analogous to what
happens in on the the propagation of
sound in a medium like air because the
speed of sound is determined by how fast
one molecule can juggle up the next
molecule could juggle up to the next
molecule and that's determined by the
characteristics of the medium but there
is an upper limit to it which is
identified in aeronautics as a Mach
number after Ernst Mach on and Mach
number one is the speed of sound and by
analogy Mach number one is the speed
that a computer can execute a data flow
with no gaps in the middle just one
thing going directly to the next to the
rec to the next you might think that
Mach 1 cannot be exceeded and in fact
i'm here to show you that it can be just
in fact as you can do it in airplanes
now for example let's take this as a
little piece of source code we've got a
big constant there that's much too big
to be done as intermediate in that and
add operation I'm assuming a load store
architecture here not something in which
like an x86 where you have but funny
extensions and huge instructions that
can carry big constants but think of
your typical risk type in
struction set and the machine code of
this is well you want to have to have
some kind of an operation that builds a
constant for you sometimes in some
machines this is more than one operation
in order to put it up in pieces other
times is some other way to do it I'll
assume the presence of a constant eye
operation there's a functioning unit
that produces a constant then that has
to be fed into an ad like that and that
in turn will have to be crossing a cycle
boundary because we had to the first to
get the constant then one cycle later
the bad data value is available to the
adder and now once the adders done its
thing that's going to be feed into a
store unit and there'll be another cycle
boundary there the dotted pink line in
all of these slides means a Psychlo
boundary anytime you see something
flowing across there it took an extra
cycle now that's the basic model in the
vliw which is a wide issue machine you
can issue several operations in parallel
in fact you might be able to have a
constant and add in a store all in one
instruction which fairly typical
arrangement for viola deputies so if
that's our same source code the machine
code might look like this where an
underscore their means all one
instruction so this is one instruction
with three operations in it we might
think that well you could have a Const
feeding to an ad feeding into a store
but unfortunately you can't do that the
whole cycle is taken up by the constant
the whole cycles taking up at the ad and
arrows don't go upwards in data flow
they only go downward so anytime you see
an arrow going upward that means this is
something that is physically impossible
those paths are impossible
so what do you do the vliw is going to
have to take three cycles just like risk
would have to take three cycles the
misfits each instruction cycle in two
phases these are not subplots we don't
actually have a whole bunch of little
clocks inside the big clock there's only
one big clock so phasing is a conceptual
model that source coder again will
produce in fact the same machine code as
the vliw uses constant and store all in
one instruction the underlined recall
means that this is in one instruction
there's our cycle boundaries the
constituent it happens there that feeds
the ad because operations in different
phases can be part of the same data flow
there is a phase boundary between the
two but not a cycle boundary and there's
a phase boundary between the ad and the
store now this is the logical view
physical reality is different that's I
used to say that when I was in the 60s
but anyway phases execute in sequence as
a data flow and each operation in the
instruction set of the machine is
associated by definition to one
particular phase the results of an OP
that each operation can have as as input
results from a prior phase here are your
phases the reader
handles those things which have no
inputs constants values read from
Specter from spec regs with from the
scratchpad scratch pad we won't address
but it's temporary storage area up phase
is all your ordinary ops your adds and
subtracts and your loads and your this
is and that's so up for anything in op
phase can see see anything that was
produced in reader fates in particular
in our example here add you can see the
result of const call phase function
calls pic is a equivalent to the ? colon
operator in NC it selects one or two
based on the selector value has it phase
all of its own and writer phase are
those things which are pure sinks and
who accept inputs but have no output in
particular stores branches and things
like that so those are your basic phases
air Constad and store which we had in
our example code the constants in reader
phase so it can pass data to the ad
which is inop phase and the ad can pass
data from up phase 2 writer phase if the
phases happen to be the same you can't
pass through but you can pass to a
subsequent phase in the phase order
listed I just described in the actual
implementation one ups from one
instruction are not issued all together
the way they would be in the vliw that
vliw if it said Const add store all of
those are happening all at once in the
same cycle that's what a VLIW does what
it is not true in a moment instead the
ops from a single operator instruction
are in fact issued over three different
cycles
if these are my three instructions in
this cycle this is instruction what
instructions to instructions free and
order in the program in this cycle the
reader phase wolf of instruction one
will be the first thing that happens
then because the cycle boundary and
instruction ones up phase execute at the
same time as the reader phase of
instruction to another cycle boundary
instruction one is reached and is
executing writer phase in structure to
was now in its op phase doing ads and
the like and destruction three is just
started up with whatever it's got for
reader phase and so on in the obvious
wet so each instruction executes over
three cycles which are one cycle phased
away from the prior and subsequent
instruction now one way of looking at
this is that the phases form an intra
instruction software pipeline values get
passed from one of the next over
multiple cycles but still within one
instruction in the way that a software
pipeline loop does it's an analogy it
can't be pushed too far but it's a way
of thinking about it now phase
assignments I alluded to this those
things which are going to be operation
which will be assigned to reader phase
will be all those that don't need any
inputs they could just be done as soon
as they get decoded up phase are those
things which need to have some inputs
and also produce results and somebody's
going to want to produce want to consume
and writer phase are pure sinks things
which will grab values but do not have
to pass them to anybody else there are
cycle boundaries between these and as a
result each phase can in fact pass to
the subsequent phase even though they
are in the same instruction because they
issue at different times how that works
with the decode on most machines and
particularly most vliw and other wide
issues all of the operations of a single
instruction are decoded simultaneously
and they're all made available to the
execution unit simultaneously not on the
mill the mill is way too wide for that
the mill is exceptionally wide at the
high end mill family of the mills you
can have 30 or more operations in a
single instruction all of which have to
do beat be decoded out of a variable
length encoding and there's a complete
video and talk on that subject at
considerable length on the site would
remember that's your homework those
instructions wind up being pulled up
through a fetch hierarchy and placed in
a micro cache which is the actual input
into the decoder so the instruction gets
sent to a decoder and that takes
crossing a cycle boundary as it goes
from the problem of the micro cash into
the decoder internally in order to
decode 30 plus operations it takes the
decoder three full cycles to be able to
do that and how it gets away with being
able to do it in only three cycles is an
interesting subject that you can read
about elsewhere meanwhile different
parts of the instruction are available
from the decoder in different cycles
some parts are available in the very
first cycle some parts take two cycles
some parts take three cycles to get
everything figured out so as each piece
comes out of out of the three different
cycles and decode they get fed to the
execute engine and the execute engine
then winds up the dear maiden two of the
blocks are available cycle before the
others out of the six blocks which incur
in an instruction
and they are arranged so that those
things which are going to want to
execute in reader phase in fact are in
the part of the instruction which is
decoded first and is available
immediately so if that's our instruction
coming in one cycle later the reader ops
can go you sent directly over to the
executor that's constitutes the reader
phase as far as the execution is
concerned meanwhile the partly decode
instruction is sent to the second stage
in the decoder and gets decoded there
and the ops resulting from that decode
gets sent over to the execute engine and
the instruction moves to yet the third
stage of the decoder where the writer
ones are decoded and sent over so the
execute the three cycles of execute
directly correspond to the three cycles
of the decode as fast as things come out
of the decode even though it is all one
instruction it's that Adi code is
spreads stretched over three cycles and
correspondingly the execution is also
stretched over three cycles the decoders
are fully pipelined and so as a result
you can initiate the decode of a new
instruction every cycle there's our
first instruction going in it goes it
produces a reader result and moves down
but meanwhile the next instruction gets
pulled in and it's partial decodes move
over execution and yet another
instruction gets pulled in and this
becomes your steady state at least if
not interrupt by a branch misprediction
which is the bane of everybody the
phases of instruction decode overlap
with the phases of the adjacent
instructions reader phase happens in the
same cycle as the op phase of the prior
instruction
and the writer phase of the instruction
before that now so much for the
arrangement how about those other phases
I only mentioned three but the phase
listed several other phases well pick
phase which is used by the pic operation
which is the ? colon primitive of C
doesn't actually use the functional unit
it's not like an ad which has an adder
instead pic actually is implemented in
the data distribution network called the
crossbar which communicates data across
the cycle boundary from one from one
cycle to the next and actually it
occupies Zuo time at all although the
slide is showing that as if there was a
pic functional unit there really isn't
it's sort of actually happening as the
cycle boundary happens and data is
getting routed so it doesn't occupy a
functional unit and we don't have to
occupy a whole cycle for a pic we can
simply slip a pic in between an equal
and a store call phase used only by the
call operation function calls occur
function calls within an instruction
occur after any prior phase of the same
instruction and the remaining phases of
that instruction are executed after the
call returns that is what happens when
you have a call is that the front half
of the instruction is executed then you
do the call and then the return comes
back and you to the back half of the
same instruction if this is your source
code the machine code will look like
that remember the underscore means this
is all one instruction it's an add a
call or a store the ad fees that you'd
think would be feeding some functional
unit what actually that function is is
in the called function so that the
result of the ad is being passed
directly into the
all the e with only just the cycle
boundary in between the collie will
execute some amount the double pink line
there means some unknown number of
cycles whatever that function does and
eventually you'll execute a return it
will then exit crossing a cycle boundary
and we're back in the original one
directly able to store the result of the
function call its reacts acute 'add but
without the operations that have already
been done well what happens if you have
more than one call that works on them
help multiple calls are executed
consecutively and an order defined by
the encoding order and the returns from
one-call returned directly into the next
called function not back to the original
instruction so if there's a piece of
code where we have nested calls the
machine code will be add call call store
and the ad will feed gene which will run
some number of operations in function G
that will return not back to the
instruction containing the ad but
directly into F which will do some
amount of work which will eventually the
last guy in the Cascade will eventually
return that value to the final store
those of you are familiar with the turn
will recognize that this is tail calls
and the mill does tail calls in hardware
for free that is a direct transfer
assuming again you didn't have a Miss
predict but they would not have in this
case
now that explains what the mechanism is
but what's the benefit there have been a
ton of papers and studies in vast
quantities of academic arguing over
exactly how much instruction level
parallelism is inherent in existing
programs many of these papers wind up if
you look at them very closely that all
they're doing is measuring their
compiler or measuring their measurement
methodology but over time for
general-purpose code and we're not
talking embedded we're not talking oh
the kinds of things that are GPU does
but for general-purpose code the
consensus is is that the operation level
parallelism that is the number of
operations which do not have
dependencies and in principle could be
executed together is in the order of two
or three on the average well it turns
out that's false in particular out of
order machines avoid it but so does the
mill say we have two data flows these
are again very simple for illustration
on a conventional machine you could do
the two cons in parallel a cycle later
you could do the add and subtract in
parallel because there's no nothing else
which is not having data dependency a
cycle layer you're going to do the two
stores in parallel sure enough operation
level parallelism of two and it takes
three cycles to do it on a mill they all
go in one cycle and the operation level
parallelism is six why because the con
the ad in the store can all be done in
one instruction in the mill and because
the mill is very wide it has no problem
at all doing say six wide instruction so
we have effectively trebled our
operation level parallelism we call it
mach 3 where the game comes about if
what you have is a very long basic block
and you're concerned about operations
than middle of the basic block the mills
phasing offers no advantage over a
conventional vliw why assume that we're
in the middle of a basic block and it's
got some number of operations with mill
phasing we would encode it this way note
that the con will in fact wind up being
executed there and the store will wind
up being executed there but it's still
one instruction as far as the code is
concerned on a VLIW didn't simply put
the con and the store in the appropriate
place the mill has not gotten any faster
than what the vliw would have done this
however is true only in the middle of a
long basic block if you are not in that
circumstance when you're adjacent to
control flow phasing does earn cycles
over a conventional eiw if for example
the basic code is there's a branch and
say it's an if-then-else and the then
part is doing our con at store and then
doing another branch to someplace else
well then mill phasing will move the con
up there and that
is true only if that branch is taken at
the circuit circuit that encircled
branch is in fact taken because only
then does that instruction in the then
part actually happen and only then does
the Khan wind up actually having already
executed in parallel with the branch
similarly the store in mill phasing will
have be a one cycle later but even
though there is a branch there the exit
branch that store will be executed
whether that branch is taken or not in
effect mill phases get moved over
control floats on a VLIW without phasing
you can't do that the only way you can
get the Conn to be executed only if
taken on a VLIW if it's in an
instruction after the branch the only
way you can get that store done don't to
take it or not basis as if the branch
which does the exit is after the store
the vliw scheduler cannot hoist the Conn
over the branch or lower the store over
the branch because if it was stood the
akan over the branch then the Conn would
be executed whether or not the branch
was taken and that's not going to be
somatically with the program asks for
and if it lowers the store over the
branch it will wind up only executing
the store if the branch went one way
rather than going the other way so
fundamentally of eli w is stuck and
cannot do this kind of mechanism phasing
in some ways it's like out of water
it approximates data flow a true data
flow machine those of you are registered
in history can look up the Manchester
mu5 and find out what a a real datum of
flow machine might be but no machine can
be fundamentally faster than your data
flow architecture it disappeared I
architectural II implant well
mathematically impossible unfortunately
a true data flow architecture requires
unbounded hardware and that's why
they're difficult to fit on a chip
consequently at all machines attempt to
approximate what a data flow
architecture does and out of order does
do that it rectally detects the presence
of the data flow in the instruction
stream and then schedules things in data
flow order with maximum overlap that's
what your haswell's and so forth they do
out of order do internally phasing in
many ways can be thought of as being a
statically scheduled out of order the
compiler knows with the data flow battle
doesn't have to go and figure it out and
hardware the way and out of order
machine does and the compiler can simply
schedule the operations such that the
data flow that the operations represent
properly overlaps with the data flows
being scheduled by other instructions
the phasing device because it doesn't
have any benefit over vliw in long codes
in the middle of loan codes it benefits
you only when you're adjacent to control
flow however control flow is
exceptionally frequent on the average
every six to ten operations are there
abouts guess what one mill instruction
is quite happy with six to ten or
operations so one of the characteristics
you see in mill code is the basic blocks
tend to be one instruction long the
whole thing no matter how much work at
story ooo out of order beats phasing
when the actual dependencies of the data
flow are not
in the phase order the phase orders
fixed on the milk you can't change it so
for example a function call whose
argument is an ad is one one cycle on a
mill but in ad one of his arguments is a
function call has to be too because the
call phase is after the OP face and ooo
which is dynamically detecting this and
dynamically scheduling can do a better
job in that case turns out well we've
done our best to order the phases in
such a way that this kind of thing
doesn't happen very much and we've been
reasonably successful where the
performance is a rough approximation to
what no o machine will do phasing beads
up out of order when the out of order
machine is issue limited the mill is
very very wide and out of order machines
are hitting hardware limits which
preclude having an issue with some more
than about eight as well i think is
eight for example so if you want to be
able to put together data flows which
together would be a dozen operations
you're actually limited you can't do
that on and out of order machine and
furthermore you're not going to be able
to do it on any out of order machine
because out of order hardware is
extraordinarily complex extraordinarily
large and extraordinarily power-hungry
and you've just hit diminishing returns
and even eight is pushing it mill does
not have these constraints it is
extremely power stingy and it puts his
area into functional units which are
tiny so the mill does not have
constraints that make an issue limited
or Lee's family members don't
so phasing is an example of something
that would of which we've had other
examples invest in various talks one of
those in the discussions of the memory
system memory introduced the notion
called a deferred load that I won't go
into but remember your homework and its
consequence of the deferred load is that
we can approximate the performance of an
outer an order machine without the power
an area overhead of actually doing a
real out of work this is another example
you will we will rarely well depends on
the complexity of the code but we will
not often actually beat an out of order
machine but we'll be in we will be
roughly at a par in terms of a total
throughput and the saving is in the
power and the area now so much for
ganging and which is the attachment of
operations temporarily in addition we
need to address the possibility of
combining operations horizontally not
temporarily but spatially that also
exists on the mill it's called ganging
it removes a source count limitation
which is President or essentially all
machines which architectures are
designed in order to have a optimize the
common case in the common case is that
that you have operations that are too
important one output like an ad and
consequently their data paths to feed
functional units let's carry the two
data in and one data out so nearly
everything has that kind of a structure
bear in mind we're using the belt so the
value data is coming in from the belt
and but it's two in and the adder takes
it takes it to input some producers one
result which goes back out the
operations are encoded the actor the bit
layout of the encoding is designed to
support this the data paths are designed
to support this and essentially all
machines do this us too
unfortunately there are operational in
and one out rule one of them is fuse
multiply atom it has three inputs and
computes a times B plus C well you might
think you could do that in fact adding a
third input into the encoding and into
the data paths to the functional
pipelines would be really expensive and
fundamentally you don't want to do it
every machine has to that supports FMA
has to deal with this and the
contortions that it uses are extreme if
you want to get into the details feel
free the middle doesn't do it quite that
way instead we define what we call a
gang these are two or more adjacent to
input data paths that cooperatively
implement a single operation those are
two two inputs each of the execution
pipelines has a perfectly normal to
input one LOL no output to input zero
output on the mill encoding slot and
each contains perfectly ordinary to
input data paths suitable for functional
units like al use of FPS and so forth
when what you want to do is a three
input those slots cooperatively
implement a single operation by defining
another operation whose name internally
is called args that has inputs but no
results well we now have two inputs
going down one path and one input going
down another path but what we really
want was three inputs so args passes its
data horizontally between the functional
units
that in turn produces a result in a
perfectly ordinary way Ganga is used for
all operations and about more than two
inputs however just having an arse up
which does nothing except taking an
input for the data pass and pass it
along horizontally seems somewhat
wasteful be nice if you could do
something else besides having the FMA
there so what's really going on well
internally to the FMA functional unit
there's a multiplier and the two inputs
get multiplied then the args value comes
in and the result of the multiply and
the result of a value government from
the args gets passed to an adder which
is also in that same functional unit
like so but we could put something do
something useful in the second slot so
let's gang together to FMA units to make
what we call f mas or fuse multiply add
subtract with four inputs the two units
the two pairs of units each go to the
multiplier the result of the two
multiplies are horizontally interchanged
and then one side doesn't add and the
other side doesn't subtract the result
is to results mill is very good at
multiple results because of the belt
structure which computes the sum and
difference of two products sometimes you
only want one you ignore the they second
or you sometimes want both for many
kinds of floating-point computations
that happens to like having both of
those yes
I'm I'm somewhat deaf and I'm going to
need someone to repeat the question
fancy that in any case some a difference
of two products making use of the
functional units that are already there
now I got backed up somehow
alternatively you could use that same
hardware there's two multipliers and two
adders to do to F mas here we need 6
inputs ok we're now going to get to
individual FMA operations and f mas like
f MA is only one rounding error and is
consequently as advantageous over the
equivalent simple multiply ad segments
ganging as i said is used for any time
you need more than two inputs but it
actually has other uses as well and i'm
going to touch on one of those which we
call predicate gangs let me introduce
you to the bane of CPU design it's
called a condition code condition codes
are side-effect byproducts of ALU
operations where bits are set typically
in the program status word that indicate
whether the ad you just did had a result
that was 0 greater than 0 less than or 0
had a carry coming out of it over float
or what have you the problem is is that
this is a global state it's real nice
you can do and subtract and get the
subtract result and in addition
immediately branch on whether they that
you have gotten 20 for example the
condition codes were designed to support
decrement a looping but the next
operation that comes along that gives is
the condition cuz just
Robert your condition cuts and when you
are doing a whole bunch of operations in
parallel all of whom set the condition
goats well who wins who does set them
and so condition codes are never used in
white issue machines in an out-of-order
machine condition codes have to be
renamed because the problem that they
will get cluttered the add-ins of
tractor not necessarily done in the
order that they look like and you have
to have multiple copies of the condition
codes it moved around like multiple
copies of the registers it is part of
the extremely complicated and
power-hungry part of making an
out-of-order machine work all of the
people who actually have to do things
like Exodus modern x86 chips do dearly
wish the condition codes had gotten left
out of the original architecture but the
original architecture did not have that
much of a view of the future on the
other hand condition codes will speed up
some kinds of code but they can't be
speculated because it's a global state
the mills very big on speculation making
use of all of its width you just need to
be able to collect the predicate
metadata of was this greater than or
less than zero or what have you and um
save it somewhere where somebody can use
it without actually saving it globally
so say that's our source code and this
is the typical bottom of a bottom of a
counting loop and are we at the end of
the loop a piece of code or we decrement
I and if it's greater than zero we will
go to the top of the loop or do
something in machine code if there are
no condition codes you have to do is
subtract on the I to decrement it and
then then you separately do a greater
than zero on the result and then you
branch of that greater return true true
in this case being a data value rather
than a condition code
with condition coats the subtracts sets
the greater than condition code and the
branch can simply branch on that
condition by the way we've saved the
cycle that's why condition codes exist
the problem of course is that that many
many operations set the codes but the
rather rarely looked at typically only
buying a branch immediately following
them the condition codes are almost
always immediately consumed or never
cared about anymore but somebody has to
keep track of them in the hardware and
they can't be speculated because its
global state so down with condition
codes in the words of idea Dykstra
condition codes considered harmful so
what you really want is to be able to
speculate it well the mill code we need
subtract and greater than branch on true
that is in fact one instruction we want
a data flow that goes from subtract to
greater do branch on true but subtract
and greater than or both up phase
operations consequently that's a no-no
and you can't do that instead it
requires this code we at least get the
greater and the branch done in parallel
do dephasing but we're still not much
better off than what a your typical risk
machine would be one possibility would
be to have the subtract produce two
results or at least some flavor of
subtractive orders to results both the
numeric nosotras result of the tract and
also a flag saying it was greater
well we could define such an operation
that call X subtract later that returns
both the difference and a boolean that's
two different results that works it
would look like that now we're just in
one instruction it's up phase and rudder
face everybody's happy except you wind
up with a huge up code explosion because
for everything that might produce a a
condition code like result you will now
have to have flavors that produce each
of the interval individual possible
conditions and your opcode space a bit
space in your encoding winds up getting
rather nastily cluttered with stuff like
that um the an implementation of this
would require the addition of another
fast path in the actual encoding the
actual mechanism passes data back and
forth that has clock impact don't worry
about the details that gentleman up
there next to the camera can explain all
about it but he's the hardware guy of
and that can do so but fundamentally
that there's good Hardware reasons why
you don't want to do this so that isn't
going to work solution we gang a
predicate the il use unconditionally and
always provide what would be a condition
code set horizontally to the adjacent
slot then we define one operation bigger
code which reads the greater better and
returns it visible this is our source
code that is our mill code the
underscore means it's all one
instruction that is a
is not passing data through the normal
data flow it had passing data across
between functional units within a cycle
and that data in turn can be passed to
the branch due to facing the gang is off
phase the gang maybe just thought of as
being a 2 slot super super operation
there's just just one operation even
though we had to break it apart into
into two pieces there's the two inputs
to the sub the greater has no inputs at
all the code gets passed from the sub to
the greater horizontally we go through
the cycle boundary the subtract result
winds up everywhere does as does the
greater result when addition the branch
run true can pick up that it's all one
instruction and we're done phasing
permits us to pick that up as being
still in the same cycle consequently
because these are numeric predicates
they get dropped in the belt like any
other just as if we had a two result
operation except that what we actually
have is two different slots producing
one result each so we don't have fast
pass problems and we don't have encoding
explosion problems and speculation is
done now there's some operations that
while you'd like to be able to issue
them in parallel they cannot execute in
parallel and control flow are the most
important of these we want to be able to
have a bunch of branches in one
instruction multi-way branches the
typical example being a switch or a case
statement depending on your favorite
language which tend to be truly annoying
in Hardware if that is our source code
the machine code will typically test for
the first case and branch to a test for
the next case and branch pretext for the
next case our branch through it and so
forth
if the cases are dense sometimes you can
load a dispatch table a table of label
variables or a table of branch offsets
but that involves having to pull stuff
out of memory and that's slow and well
there are a whole lot of solutions in
under them very satisfactory that you'll
find in architectures of various
machines typically however most
compilers today will turn this into a
chain of individual if tests though they
will optimize certain cases the problems
are is that the tests and branches
execute sequentially you're going to
wind up with a prediction for each of
those branches and they tend to clutter
the prediction tables it's possible for
the sequence to miss predicts several
times because the the predictions will
zoom down and say oh this must be case
three and we'll send the execution unit
off to the corresponding case it's
discovered that this was wrong we unwind
everything go and test the next case and
in the absence of three it now predicts
that five is going to be taken and it
turns out that five wasn't taken either
and the correct thing we should have
done was go to the default case but
meanwhile we've taken to to miss
predicts and miss predicts on a
conventional machine or exceptionally
painful the mill only has a five cycle
miss predict penalty as opposed to the
15 or 20 typical of other machines but
five cycles is painful for us too so
what we do is we put all of the thing in
one instruction the equals feed only
their respective branches they can be
done in parallel because there's no data
connection between them they're both up
phase but they both can be executed
simultaneously the data will
flow to the two branches which are both
in writer phase they don't have any data
inter connection so they can be executed
in parallel however of course only one
of those should win in this case
numerically only one is possible but
indeed other conditions it could be that
more than one had its it's there taken
untaken predicate true we define a rule
such that in encoding order the first
taken branch is taken and if there are
more we don't care so the first encoding
even though they're all executed only
one actually reroutes the core execution
the first one there is only one
prediction for the holes for the whole
switch the mill predicts exits rather
than branches and that has been
thoroughly covered in a talk called
prediction that you will find in your
homework assignment no more than one
miss predict is possible we by the time
we come back having discovered that we
were wrong we now have got the correct
value and only but what we will in fact
take the correct branch so in brief
summary you can do intra in structured
data flow if every phase is occupied you
can wind up having a substantial
expansion but in practice codes do not
contain on every phase in a data flow we
find that a Mach 3 is recently
representative it is heavily dependent
on the application in the nature of the
code and it's also dependent on the
width of the particular family member
low end machines no end mills do not
have
all that much width and there might be
implicitly a parallelism available that
we can't use because it's not in a
functional units at the high end it
tends to be not a problem single
instructions are issued over three
cycles effectively what we have is
pseudo out of order that operates at
execute operations over control flow the
way a hardware out of order does we can
have instructions containing multiple
calls which means the data flows can
have contain multiple calls two cascaded
calls are automatically tale called only
the last one returns to the original
instruction this n way branching in one
instruction and the compiler and the
hardware both know what's going to
happen and schedule the code accordingly
we're not constrained by pipeline data
paths because we can gang assuming that
the underlying of the functional
capacity is there consequently we can
support novel operations which I've mmm
puts and outputs that other machines
simply do not have including perhaps
specialized operations for certain
particular market areas and has
spectacle condition codes so you get the
performance gain on it without global
state there i will leave the slide up
there you can find additional
documentation the mailing list we'll get
you on our mailing list for
announcements of talks like this which
take place sorry and they takes place
elsewhere although you could sign us up
for another one next semester if you
wanted and there's announcements of
things like the white paper available it
isn't in such like
I'm open to questions is there an LLVM
compiler for your machine and is it
possible to slurp up real boat and
you're in the mist patent filing so we
cannot expose a bunch of stuff to talk
about in these talks and things the
patents have brought in but to
completely expose the machine we cannot
yet do that said that doesn't matter
because the compiler doesn't work we had
a compiler which was based on the EDG
front to end the one which goes into the
Intel IC c compiler and our own middle
and back ends and it was up to the point
where it would generate code and we
realized that this was completely wrong
headed we do not want to roll our own
especially not all the middle and
optimizations for vectorization which is
well-established technology and there's
no point in us repeating it and so we
made the decision to convert to discard
our old one and convert to llvm that was
at the point when the Patent Office
changed its rules and we realized we had
to immediately who had to come out of
stealth and merely spy us start filing
patents and frankly I am so sick of
patents because we've been doing nothing
except file patents for the last year
and unfortunately the llvm effort has
been set aside we just recently added a
new person to the team who's taking that
on and there will be some major work
having to be done even with llvm because
llvm makes some very rash assumptions
for example it assumes it's running on a
register machine and we are not but we
have we have done enough work to know
where at least some of the bodies are
buried in llvm or mill on the llvm but
it's it is definitely a major piece of
work still to go by the time however
that work is done all the patents will
be in will have benchmarks available all
the rest of
thing else so it doesn't really matter
because we have to block things and
they'll come out the back end roughly
the same time we think we hope I'm the
I'm a compiler guy I've done 11
compilers so it's there's a lot of work
in there but we believe in part because
we already did one to the compiler we
believe we understand what the issues
will be and our major difficulties will
in fact be not with our stuff but
without obeah we think for for for your
ticket on the shin how many MPG belt and
call me fourth season right else they've
till you confront your gate region right
mmm how many bell positions and how many
loads and stores me leave them dry
sports what I mean I mean blood
murmuring start a memory hello the bell
bell what about all dream yeah it's a
family like the 360 was a family these
parameters vary my family member the
smallest one we have currently specified
for configuration as a belt length of
eight operates the largest one we have
is 32 operands it's pretty clear that
there's no point in anything smaller
than eight it's not clear that's whether
64 would be useful but we believe not
you want to have the belt size to track
the number of functional units because
the number of functional units
determines how many new values can drop
each cycle you have six adders you can
drop 6ad results and you want to have
enough belt so that those results get
used before they fall off the end so as
you get more functional units you also
want to extend the belt to match it is
this purity of pragmatic sizing based on
sim
so is that correct let's say 430 units
pure 30 units you would have 32
registers and your belt and make up
basically nine supports again the 32
belt you'd have 32 registers in your
belt and 90 some ports okay these are
not registration well they're registered
in a sensitive foot pump it has think
there's a knife like sloppy but does not
flip flops either the the belt has been
discussed in a prior talk and with
without slides or whiteboard would be a
bit to explain it the conceptual model
of it being a colossal shift register is
false it doesn't actually work that way
there is no colossal shift register the
thing there are it is not implemented as
an SRAM array it is not implemented as a
register file consequently the notion of
ports is not meaningful you go to the
homework page in your head you'll see
how it works the only alternative is a
multiplexer tree a pipeline multiplexer
dream right I mean that's the one we
made no no well is essentially the
bypass network that a conventional
machine has it's a it's a it's it's must
reach ok
the way the addressing happens is to a
naming process when something which was
formerly called be three becomes b5 all
this changes the name no data bits of
moves timeouts in time past which caused
the name check yes yeah so um eight belt
positions or 16 or 32 or whatever the
equivalent of object code that's running
on the machine would have different size
fields depending on yes also it seems
that at some point things will fall off
the end of the belt and there will be
cases where that you so long as it yet
so definitely they will fall into I'll
address both questions that I could hear
you I'm sorry folks I'm slightly deaf
and I need some help with respect to
things falling off the end separately
there is a facility called the
scratchpad this is not memory it is an
upper and store it retains values and
internal format which was not the same
as I as a memory format and there are
operations that say this value on the
belt park it in the scratch pad and
later on another operation that says get
it from the scratch pad and drop it on
the belt so values which need to be kept
for long term because their users not
get coming up yet or their last use is
not your coming up yet wind up being
explicitly moved to the scratchpad the
great majority of operations that are
produced are immediately used once and
immediately there immediately debt
register death in a register machine is
extremely high there'll be a some kind
of case people will use a register as
fast memory but the four things which
are actually intermediate results they
tend to if your compilers doing a
halfway decent job of
our scheduling produces adjacent to
consumers and that their lifetime is
very brief and the great majority of
them if we sized the belt appropriately
the great majority of them will and fall
off the belt because they're past the
their last shoots but for those that are
they get dropped to the scratch pad and
the other goal of encoding not only does
each family member have a unique binary
encoding but each encoding slot has a
unique binary encoding if this slot has
got an ALU and an FPU then it has to
support both integer and floating-point
operations and our software produces a
binary encoding that encodes both
integer and floating-point operations
the adjacent slab which has only got an
ALU and not an FBO has its own unique
encoding that only contains the integer
operations and not the floating-point
operations these in coatings are
mechanically generated from a
specification nobody does this by hand
nobody lays out bits the specification
simply says in this slot is this
function unit and separately that
functionally your supports blah blah
blah blah blah blah and blah and the
software which has been running for
years is long stable software it
proceeds to produce a entropy optimal
encoding with some special things so as
to improve the life of the decoder
beyond simple optimal entropy and that's
mechanically generated and the trivial
change you got a completely different
binary encoding the way you're able to
handle on the binary portability which
of course is important is the same way
that it's done in the IM the IBM as400
and its descendants and that is that
what actually appears in your load
module is a member independent
representation of the program
and at install or potentially load time
if it's that late or if you're building
it wrong a program which effectively is
the last phase of the compiler we call
it the specialized err translates the
member independent representation the
program to the actual Bitsy's for that
member that targeted member dependent
representation is then cashed in the
load module the next time you run it we
simply pull up that binary but if you
take the file off to another machine the
loader will look and say oh you don't
have a cached version of my machine runs
the specialized err look kind of like
dynamic linking it runs a bit once for
you for free cash the nuke the new one
and you end and this is the equivalent
of a strip tool which remove or your
excess cash ones that you don't want
this to save disk space and so forth
yeah
you